Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker has proven
to be a bit divisive among fans - but in an
alternate universe, they were divided by a
totally different movie.
George Lucas had his own plans for the sequel
trilogy before selling Lucasfilm to Disney
in 2012, and it's safe to say that his conclusion
to the Skywalker Saga would have borne little
resemblance to the film we got.
A key piece of information we have concerning
Lucas' vision for the ninth episode of the
main Star Wars series comes from Mark Hamill,
Luke Skywalker himself, in an interview the
star gave to IGN in March 2018.
Now that Rise of Skywalker has been unleashed
on the world, there is new context for his
remarks - and it's interesting to take stock
of how the creator's plans shifted due to
the involvement of new creatives and unforeseen
circumstances.
Specifically, Hamill noted that while Lucas
had indeed planned to kill off Luke, he didn't
intend to do so until the end of Episode 9;
you'll recall that Luke essentially sacrificed
himself at the conclusion of Star Wars: The
Last Jedi in order to allow the besieged remains
of the Resistance to escape the First Order
onslaught on Crait.
In Lucas' version of the sequel trilogy, though,
Luke would have had another order of business
to attend to in the next film: training his
sister, Leia, in the ways of the Jedi.
In his talk with IGN, Hamill lamented that
this narrative thread was, quote, "never played
upon" in The Last Jedi, even though that film
- the only one of the sequel flicks to be
co-written and directed by Rian Johnson rather
than J.J. Abrams - was reportedly more in
line with Lucas' vision for the trilogy.
Of course, it goes without saying that Fisher's
death in 2016 resulted in Leia's role in The
Last Jedi and The Rise of Skywalker being
greatly diminished, although given Lucas'
affinity for CGI, it doesn't necessarily follow
that this would have been the case had he
remained in charge.
It's pretty easy to pinpoint some of the other
major ways in which Lucas' sequel trilogy
would have differed from the one we got; for
one thing, they would have centered on completely
different characters, as Rey, Poe, Finn, and
Kylo Ren were not his creations.
Yes, Lucas did intend to bring back Luke,
Leia, and Han Solo - but in regard to Rise
of Skywalker in particular, there's one returning
character from that film that would not have
made the cut in Lucas' version.
This would be Ian McDiarmid's Emperor Palpatine,
whose controversial return was Abrams' idea
and whose big comeback McDiarmid recently
admitted to being blindsided by, for a simple
reason.
Speaking with Digital Spy, the actor revealed
that Lucas had no further plans for the character
- at least not in terms of the films' in-universe
chronology - after his apparent demise during
the climax of Star Wars: Return of the Jedi.
McDiarmid said:
"I thought I was dead!
I thought [Palpatine] was dead."
"Because when we did Return of the Jedi, and
I was thrown down that chute to Galactic Hell...
I said, 'Oh, does he come back?'
And George said, 'No, he's dead.'"
McDiarmid went on to say that he had accepted
his character's fate, up until the prequels.
"In a sense he wasn't dead, because we went
back to revisit him when he was a young man.
But I was totally surprised by this."
We can also glean from Lucas' own remarks
that, while the iconic principal characters
from the original trilogy would have played
a major role in his version of the trilogy,
the focus of the plot would have been... slightly
more esoteric than Disney's.
In 2018, a quote from the companion book to
the AMC docu-series James Cameron's Story
of Science Fiction made the rounds online,
and it revealed that Lucas had at one point
been prepared to take the story in directions
nobody could have foreseen.
The director explained:
"[The sequel films] were going to get into
a microbiotic world.
There's this world of creatures that operate
differently than we do.
I call them the Whills.
And the Whills are the ones who actually control
the universe.
They feed off the Force...
If I'd held onto the company I could have
done it..."
Given many observers' gripes that the Disney
sequel trilogy suffered from a lack of overall
cohesive vision, Lucas' version may even have
proven to be more satisfying for the franchise's
fans.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.